u.s officials say the american military
withdrawal from afghanistan will likely
be complete by this sunday
july 4th that will leave afghan forces
on their own to defend their country
against taliban militants
who are on the offensive charlie dagetta
got a
very close look at the fighting that is
drawing closer
to afghanistan's capital a trip to the
taliban front line from
kabul used to mean getting a lift on a
helicopter
now it's just a drive away into the
mountains outside the capitol
they're that close at the combat outpost
in capiza province northeast of kabul a
concerned commander directed his gunman
toward approaching taliban fighters
seconds later the outpost came under
attack
jesus christ bullets ricocheted off the
rocks
from the moment we arrived here these
afghan forces opened fire on taliban
militants were trying to advance up the
valley
and had opened fire on this location
that is how fluid the front line is here
this outpost fell to the taliban just
the day before until they were pushed
back
with the snipers so there's some there's
sometimes snipers in that valley yeah
so we have to stay back
in the absence of u.s troops holding the
line against the taliban
takes a combination of afghan army
security forces and civilian fighters
known as uprising militias
who have taken up arms hyderabh zali is
the defense committee chairman
how important are the as you call them
uprising people
they're very important and they are they
play a vital role
for for the security of the overall
afghanistan
an afghan humvee came racing back toward
us in the valley below
under fire and blasting its guns in a
fighting retreat
then a whole column we were told it was
time to leave
taliban militants were advancing and no
one was certain they could be stopped
twenty years after u.s forces came here
they leave behind a country
that is now on the verge of an all-out
civil war
for cbs this morning charlie dagetta
capiza province
afghanistan in the thick of it there in
afghanistan are charlie dagetta thank
you very much